my father was a lighthouse keeper  my mother was queen but life has a way  of bringing people together could unite  our bones one day check it out author is  talking to the fish  they may be what I am  listen to come aboard  [Music]  I've been looking for you your half  brother King arm is about to declare war  upon the surface world  the only way to stop this war is for you  to take your rightful place as king  trust me I know you do your best  thinking when you're not thinking at all  that was the worst pep talk ever  I want to strap in  my brother has come from the service  let's meet for the throne I got an  ass-whooping  no leader  I came because I had no choice  to save my own  people that are loved  you think you're on medieval lead which  is your two different worlds  that is exactly why you are worthy  oh it's awesome  the war is coming to the surface  and I'm bringing the wrath of the seven  seas with me  [Music]  what are you doing parachute right hoods  you gotta love  you